>> NOW, FINALLY, PUTTING AMERICA
FIRST.
FIRST, WE'LL INVEST IN THE
AMERICAN WORKER.
WE WILL BREATHE NEW LIFE INTO
YOUR VERY RUNDOWN HIGHWAYS,
RAILWAYS AND WATERWAYS.
WE'LL TRANSFORM OUR ROADS AND
BRIDGES FROM A SOURCE OF ENDLESS
FRUSTRATION INTO A SOURCE OF
ABSOLUTELY INCREDIBLE PRIDE.
I'VE ASKED REPUBLICANS AND
DEMOCRATS IN CONGRESS TO COME
TOGETHER AND DELIVER THE BIGGEST
AND BOLDEST INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN
IN THE LAST HALF CENTURY, PLAN
GENERATES AN UNPRECEDENTED $1.5
TRILLION INVESTMENT IN AMERICAN
INFRASTRUCTURE.
>> Bret: THE PRESIDENT IN OHIO
WITH THIS PLAN ON INFRASTRUCTURE
KIND OF LAYING THAT OUT IN A
VERY CAMPAIGN STYLE SPEECH FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE BULLET POINTS HERE, $200
BILLION IN FEDERAL FUNDING TO
SPUR, AS HE MENTIONED, $1.5
TRILLION IN INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENTS.
KIND OF A PUBLIC/PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIP.
$100 BILLION FOR INCENTIVES
PROGRAM.
FOR ADDITIONAL INVESTMENTS,
STATES, LOCALITIES, PRIVATE
SECTOR, $20 BILLION PROMOTING
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS, $20
BILLION EXPANDING THE FINANCING
PROGRAMS.
$10 BILLION IN CAPITAL REVOLVING
FUND TO HELP REDUCE INEFFICIENT
FEDERAL PROPERTY LEASING.
WHAT ABOUT THIS?
LET'S BRING IN OUR PANEL.
KATIE, NEWS EDITOR AT
TOWNHALL.COM.
AND BILL McGURN, MAIN COLUMNIST
FOR "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL."
BILL, REALISTIC?
>> IT'S A LITTLE REALISTIC.
LOOK, THE PROBLEM ISN'T CAN WE
BUILD THIS STUFF?
THERE'S TWO PROBLEMS.
WHO IS GOING TO PAY FOR IT?
AND CAN WE GET PERMISSION TO
BUILD IT FROM THE REGULATORY
PROCESS?
SO THOSE ARE THE AREAS I THINK
WHERE THE PRESIDENT COULD HAVE A
LITTLE MORNING IMPACT.
YOU KNOW, WE NEED A REFORM OF
HOW IT'S DONE.
IN NEW YORK AND NEW JERSEY, FOR
EXAMPLE, SO MUCH OF THIS SHOULD
HAVE BEEN DONE BY THE LOCAL AND
STATE GOVERNMENTS.
BUT BECAUSE OF THE SPENDING
PROBLEMS THAT THEY HAVE, THEY
DONNY  -- DON'T HAVE THE MONEY
FOR IT.
>> THERE'S SOME CITIES AND
STATES THIS IS NOT A REALISTIC
PROSPECT BECAUSE IT REQUIRES
THEM TO COME UP WITH SO MUCH OF
THE MONEY.
THERE'S TRADITIONALLY BEEN AN
80/20 FEDERAL, STATE SPLIT.
THIS PUTS IT THE OTHER WAY
AROUND, PUTTING 20% OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE SPENDING.
NOW, THAT'S SAID, THERE'S A
BIPARTISAN ACROSS THE COUNTRY
CONSENSUS THAT WE NEED TO HAVE A
BIGGER INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE.
BUT I'M NOT SURE THE PRESIDENT'S
PLAN IS ONE THAT IS POLITICALLY
FEASIBLE AND I THINK THE
PROSPECTS THAT IT GETS THROUGH
CONGRESS THIS YEAR ARE PRETTY
SLIM.
>> Bret: WE WENT THROUGH THIS
OMNIBUS AND I TALKED TO GOVERNOR
DANIELS ABOUT THAT.
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE BIG
LEGISLATIVE THINGS ARE GOING TO
HAPPEN PRIOR TO THE MIDTERMS.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> WELL, ACCORDING TO THE WHITE
HOUSE SENIOR OFFICIAL TODAY,
THEY'RE NOT LOOKING FOR THIS TO
BE A BIG INFRASTRUCTURE PLAN IN
TERMS OF IT BEING ONE BIG PIECE
OF LEGISLATION.
THEY ACTUALLY WANT TO MOVE THIS
IN PARTS.
THEY WANT CERTAIN COMMITTEES ON
CAPITOL HILL TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THE DETAILS AND PUSH THEM
THROUGH INDIVIDUALLY.
SO I DO THINK THAT THERE IS A
CHANCE THAT SOME OF THESE THINGS
CAN GET PAST IN BITES AND PIECES
RATHER THAN IN A BIGGER PIECE OF
LEGISLATION.
BUT I WANT TO GO BACK QUICKLY TO
THE STATES ISSUE.
YES, THE STATES ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO TAKE ON A LOT OF
RESPONSIBILITY HERE.
YOU CAN ARGUE BECAUSE OF THAT,
THERE WILL BE MORE
ACCOUNTABILITY IN TERMS OF THE
TYPES OF PROJECTS THAT THEY DO
AND THEY HAVE TO TAKE A LOOK AT
THINGS THEY ACTUALLY NEED RATHER
THAN GOING BACK TO THE STIMULUS
TYPE PACKAGE THAT WE HAD WITH
LITTLE ACCOUNTABILITY AND ALL OF
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MONEY
JUST GETTING DUMPED IN FOR THE
SAKE OF DOING PROJECTS.
STATES ARE GOING TO TAKE A LOOK
MAKE SURE THE MONEY THEY ARE
PUTTING ON THE TABLE AND THE
MONEY THEY'RE GETTING FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS WELL SPENT
TO BETTER THEIR INFRASTRUCTURE
IN THEIR STATES.
>> Bret: I MEAN, CLEARLY, BILL,
THERE IS A PROCESS THAT IS TOUGH
TO GO THROUGH IF YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO ANY BIG PROJECT IN ANY
STATE THAT THE HOOPS THAT YOU
HAVE TO GO THROUGH, THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO AFFECT.
>> YEAH, BUT BACK TO KATIE'S
POINT, I THINK IT'S A GOOD
POINT.
YOU KNOW, IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS GOING TO PICK UP
MOST OF THE TAB, THERE'S NOT A
LOT OF INCENTIVE FOR STATES TO
BE CAREFUL ABOUT THE MONEY BEING
SPENT.
YOU KNOW, IN NEW YORK, OF
COURSE, WE HAVE THIS ISSUE WITH
THE GATEWAY PROJECT, THE NEW
TUNNEL AND, YOU KNOW, NINE OUT
OF 10 PEOPLE WHO WOULD USE THAT
ARE PEOPLE LIKE ME, LOCAL
COMMUTERS.
AND SO I WOULD THINK WHY SHOULD
SOMEONE IN MISSISSIPPI HAVE TO
PAY FOR THAT?
OR HAVE TO PAY FOR THE BULK OF
THAT?
SO I THINK WE NEED -- WHAT WOULD
BE NICE IS A LOT OF REFORM THAT
CREATES INCENTIVES FOR STATES TO
FOCUS ON WHAT THEY REALLY NEED.
AND START TO PAY FOR IT
THEMSELVES.
>> Bret: DONALD TRUMP, THE
PRESIDENT TODAY, HAD ONE COMPANY
IN HIS SIGHTS.
HE TWEETED OUT "I HAVE STATED MY
CONCERNS WITH AMAZON LONG BEFORE
THE ELECTION.
UNLIKE OTHERS, THEY PAY LITTLE
OR NO TAXES TO STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
USE OUR POSTAL SYSTEM AS THEIR
DELIVERY BOY CAUSING TREMENDOUS
LOSS TO THE U.S.
AND ARE PUTTING MANY THOUSANDS
OF RETAILERS OUT OF BUSINESS."
SUSAN, IT SEEMS LIKE HE HAS
AMAZON, PERHAPS, IN HIS SIGHTS.
>> HE DOES AND THERE MAY BE A
VARIETY OF REASONS WHY.
HE'S CRITICIZED AMAZON BEFORE.
AND LINKED JEFF BEZOS WHO OWNS
AMAZON WITH "THE WASHINGTON
POST" WHICH HE ALSO OWNS.
AND THAT -- SOME PEOPLE THINK
THAT'S PART OF HIS MOTIVATION
FOR TAKING ON AMAZON.
IT IS TRUE THAT AMAZON HAS BEEN
DISRUPTIVE FOR A LOT OF SMALL
BUSINESSES IN COMMUNITIES.
AND THAT'S A FAIR CONVERSATION
TO HAVE.
IT IS NOT ACCURATE TO SAY THAT
AMAZON DOES NOT COLLECT SALES
TAX, HOWEVER.
SINCE LAST APRIL, APRIL OF 2017,
SO FOR THE LAST YEAR, AMAZON HAS
COLLECTING SALES TAX WHEREVER
THERE ARE -- STATES WHERE SALES
TAX IS LEVIED.
THAT'S A CRITICISM THAT USED TO
BE MADE AGAINST AMAZON THAT I
THINK IS NOW A LITTLE OUT OF
DATE.
>> Bret: HERE'S STEVE FORBES
ASKED ABOUT THIS KIND OF
FOCUSING IN ON ONE COMPANY.
BIG COMPANY.
AMAZON.
>> FREE MARKETS WILL WORK IN
BRINGING THAT COMPANY DOWN JUST
AS IT DOES WITH ANY OTHER
COMPANY OVER TIME.
I'M OLD ENOUGH TO REMEMBER G.M.
WHEN THAT WAS THE BIG, BAD
COMPANY.
I.B.M. WHEN THAT WAS THE BIG,
BAD COMPANY.
>> AND MICROSOFT.
>> WAL-MART WAS GOING TO TAKE
OVER THE WORLD.
NOW IT'S STRUGGLING.
LET THE FREE MARKETS PLAY OUT.
>> Bret: KATIE?
>> YEAH, I UNDERSTAND THE
PRESIDENT'S WILLINGNESS AND URGE
TO LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD
CERTAINLY.
BUT IF HE'S GOING AFTER JEFF
BEZOS AND AMAZON FOR PERSONAL
REASONS, THEN IT'S CERTAINLY AN
ABUSE OF POWER.
LOOK, STATES HAVE TAKEN THIS ON
THEMSELVES IN TERMS OF LOOKING
AT THE WAY THAT AMAZON DOES
THIRD PARTY SALES AND
IMPLEMENTED THEIR OWN TYPE OF
SALES TAX.
I ALSO BELIEVE THAT THE FREE
MARKET WILL COME INTO PLAY HERE.
OTHER THING, TOO, THERE IS
SUPREME COURT PRECEDENCE FOR
THIS GOING BACK TO THE 1990s
WHEN CATALOGS WERE SELLING GOODS
FROM STATE TO STATE AND SALES
TAX WAS NOT BEING PAID IN STATES
THEY WERE NOT ACTUALLY LOCATED.
AND THE SUPREME COURT RULED IN
FAVOR OF THE CATALOG.
AMAZON IS A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
AND THE SUPREME COURT WILL HEAR
A CASE IN APRIL DEALING WITH THE
TECH SIDE OF THAT.
BUT WE HAVE SEEN THAT THIS IS
NOT JUST AN AMAZON ISSUE.
THERE IS SOME LEGAL PRECEDENT
HERE ABOUT THE TAXES AND THE WAY
THAT THEY WORK WHEN YOU'RE
SELLING FROM A THIRD PARTY OR
FROM A DIFFERENT STATE.
>> Bret: LOT OF STATES AND
CITIES ARE COURTING AMAZON FOR A